well thank you very much this group gets
bigger and bigger this is a big group by
any standard this is like the Academy
Awards used to be before they went
political now nobody cares but great
honor to be with you we're doing very
well Mexico is doing a great job at the
border really helping us we want the
Democrats to help us as much as Mexico
and we'll have absolutely no problem at
the border we'll clean it up very
quickly but the agreement with Mexico
has been great they've been working very
hard we're we're doing very well
together good relationship yes in his
speech today Joe Biden will say that
your policies represent an existential
threat to this nation what do you say to
Joe by well I heard fighting who is a
loser I mean look Joe never got more
than 1% except Obama took him off the
trash heap and now it looks like he's
failing it looks like his friends from
the left are going to overtake him
pretty soon but I heard he you know his
whole campaign is to hit Trump you look
at what the Obama administration did in
terms of the military in terms of
security in terms of other nations in
terms of almost everything much of it
now fortunately for everybody here has
been overturned but look when a man has
to mention my name
76 times in his speech that means he's
in trouble
now I have to tell you he's a different
guy he looks different than he used to
he acts different than he used to
he's even slower than he used to be so I
don't know but when he mentions my name
that many times I guess I should be
complimented
I never do my fall numbers are great by
the way
we've gotten fantastic numbers I guess
Rasmussen just came out with a 50% and
the amazing thing is all I do is get hit
by this phony witch-hunt although they
don't mention Russia anymore because it
was no collusion so now they want to try
and say well did he obstruct a no
collusion so there was no crime the
crime was by the Democrats folks they've
committed in my opinion many crimes and
time will tell what happens there but
the crime was by the Democrats my poll
numbers have been very very good we're
starting really next week it's going to
be something I think very special we're
starting in Orlando
[Music]
cheers me
no I'd rather run against I think Biden
than anybody I think he's the weakest
mentally and I like running against
people that are weak mentally I think
Joe is the weakest up here the other
ones have much more energy I don't agree
with their policies but I think Joe is a
man who was I call him 1% Joe because
until Obama came along he didn't do very
well but I'd left look but I don't bring
them up the best thing that ever
happened to the farmers is me
we gave 16 billion dollars to the
farmers to make up for the deficit with
China we gave them 16 billion we don't
give them and if they earn it because if
Patriots we gave them ethanol at 15
which nobody was ever going to do which
Biden didn't do in eight years is you
know vice-president the farmers are my
best friend nobody has treated the
farmers better than Donald Trump
do you have an agreement with Mexico to
become a safe third country for asylum
seekers
that's the agreement that everybody says
they don't have so no because I'm going
to let Mexico do the announcement at the
right time from Mexico they want to go
through but here's the agreement it's a
very simple agreement this is one page
this is one page of a very long and very
good agreement for both Mexico and the
United States without the tariffs we
would have had nothing we had nothing
two weeks ago
Mexico told us absolutely I don't know
where the time's got the story but I
think they got it probably for somebody
that worked here and said oh how well
they would do well for a long time for
many years people tried to get what we
got in a period of a couple of days and
they couldn't get it that's the
difference they couldn't get it so
Mexico we're getting along with them
great marcelo and the president and all
of them were getting along great they've
started a very strong action they're
moving right now 6,000 soldiers to their
southern border whoever heard of that
you think we had that two weeks ago two
weeks ago I'll tell you what we had we
had nothing and the reason we had
nothing is because Mexico felt they
didn't have to give us anything I don't
blame them but this is actually
ultimately going to be good for Mexico
too and it's good for the relationship
of Mexico with us so here's your thing
you know they all say oh he doesn't I
just give you my word inside here and I
would love to do it but you will freeze
action it you will stop it you will
analyze it every single letter you'll
see but in here is my is the agreement
Nancy is a mess
the Democratic Party is a mess they're
doing everything they can to win the
election in 2020 they are guilty of many
crimes many many crimes what they've
done they're guilty of many many crimes
and hopefully in a short period of time
that'll be seen they should never have
done what they've done and all they do
is waste time on these investigations
where there's no obstruction no
collusion no nothing and in the meantime
they can't get a border deal done they
can't do anything we need in addition to
the great deal with Mexico we need them
to work on illegal immigration on lower
drug prices on infrastructure and
they're not doing anything they are
they've come to a halt agreed did Mexico
agree and sorry did Mexico agreed in the
negotiations last week to become a safe
third country for asylum I don't want to
say but you can just figure it out
yourself right here and the reason is
Mexico wants to handle that would have
to go through their their legislative
body a lot of people are they agree to a
lot of people are saying that good luck
okay I'm not going to say one way the
other but I will tell you right here is
the story you know I don't like it when
newspapers write fake news or when
reporters like you do fake news I don't
like that so right here is the agreement
it's very simple it's right here and in
here is everything you want to talk
about done
[Music]
Joe Biden thought that China was not a
competitor of us Joe Biden is a dummy
Joe Biden thought China was not a
competitor China made five hundred
billion dollars over a short period of
time against Obama Biden and for many
many years in all fairness to them China
is a major competitor and right now
China wants to make a deal very badly
it's me right now that's holding up the
deal and we're gonna need to do a great
deal with China but we're not doing the
deal at all right now China is paying us
billions and billions of dollars they
never gave us ten cents and China ate
our country alive during Obama and Biden
they ate us alive and then Biden has
some kind of relationship financially or
son with China tell me about that
because China ate the United States
alive economically and it's a shame
below she attacked me she was here she
made a horrible statement that I'm sure
she wish she didn't make she made a
horrible statement while I was with the
Queen of England while I was with while
I was with the president of France and
you're not supposed to do that ok but
the ones that committed the crimes are
the Democrats and others
we're looking at that and we're very
much involved with the Venezuela crisis
it's a horrible thing a horrible
situation it's been brewing for many
years it really started in the worst
form during the bitin Obama
administration but it's been brewing for
a long time so we're looking at that
very strongly
bunchy your tweet about she and the
threat of terrorists if he doesn't meet
with you where are you on that
my relationship with President Xi of
China is a very good one one of the
people I really like I get along with
him right he's representing China I'm
representing the United States of
America we're doing very well which they
get in billions and billions of dollars
companies are leaving China right now
and they're coming here because they
don't want to pay the tariffs and
they're going to other countries but I
think that China I can tell you China
would like to make a deal very badly
they're getting hurt very badly by the
tariffs because companies can't pay the
tariffs so they're leaving China and the
other thing you have to remember about
China is that China will subsidize
companies so our taxpayer is not paying
for very much of it a report came out
they're paying for very little of it but
what it's doing is creating a fair
playing field which we've never had with
China since the WTO the World Trade
Organization
we expect to beat with President Xi very
shortly we think we'll meet him at the
g20 we're talking we have a very good
relationship look we had a deal with
China and then they went back in the
deal they said we don't want to have
four major points five major points so
we change it but we had to deal with
China and unless they go back to that
deal I have no interest right now we're
taking in billions and billions of
dollars I've created something what
we've done in the last two and a half
years we've picked up 14 trillion
dollars in net worth of the United
States and China has gone down probably
by 20 trillion there's a tremendous gap
when I came in that gap was getting very
close
[Music]
well I love Iowa I've gotten along great
I won Iowa by a lot the last time
usually a Republican win win it would
not win it by that much but I won Iowa
as you know by a lot I have a great
relationship with the farmers I have a
great relationship with everybody I mean
Iowa I think it's going to be something
that we wouldn't very easily I think
we're going to win I saw a fake poll a
suppression fall in Pennsylvania I even
saw one in Texas there's suppression
there fake polls just like the fake
media of which there are many here
they're fake pulse we're going to win
Texas by a lot we're going to win Iowa
by a lot we're going to win
I would say every Pennsylvania I think
we're going to do very well we have
steel companies opening up that for 40
years they didn't open up steel
companies now they're opening up now I
think we're doing very well
so I see that and I just received a
beautiful letter from Kim jong-un and I
think the relationship is very well but
I appreciated the letter I saw the
information about the CIA with respect
to his brother or half-brother and I
would tell him that would not happen
under my under my auspices that's for
sure I wouldn't I wouldn't let that
happen under my auspices but I just
received a beautiful letter from Kim
jong-un I can't tell you the letter
obviously but it was a very personal
very warm very nice letter I appreciate
it and I'll say it again I think that
North Korea has tremendous potential and
he'll be there I think that North Korea
under his leadership but North Korea
because of what it represents the people
are great the land is great the location
is incredible between Russia China and
South Korea I think North Korea has
tremendous potential and the one that
feels that more than anybody is Kim
jong-un he gets it he totally gets but I
don't know I I have not heard about that
but I would but I want to get it further
advanced in the meantime no nuclear
testing
no major missile testing nothing like
when I first got here when I first got
here it was a bad mess we have a very
good relationship together now I can
confirm it because of the letter I got
yesterday and I think you know I think
that something will happen that's going
to be very positive but in the meantime
we have our hostages back the remains
keep coming back we have a relation
say it I don't know what to think about
that I know this that the relationship
is such that that wouldn't happen under
my auspices but I don't know about that
nobody knows a little higher
Congress has to get their act together
they have to pass immigration laws they
have to get rid of I mean as far as I'm
concerned the most important thing is to
get rid of the loopholes because you
have loopholes and asylum problems that
they could do in 15 minutes if they
wanted to the Democrats in Congress are
causing this country tremendous drug
problems tremendous security problems
and they have to get together and they
have to work out asylum and the
loopholes it would take literally 15
minutes it's so simple
we're going to do is we're going to sit
down at some point with the Democrats
we're going to work it all out it is a
quick negotiation and they know I'm
right they just don't want to do it
politically they want to have open
borders and open borders mean crime it
really means crime it means drugs so we
get 90% of our drugs coming in through
the southern border which I think
everyone pretty much agrees to hundreds
of billions of dollars we can close it
up so easy now we took a big step with
Mexico over the last three days this is
an even bigger step but we took a big
step with Mexico the Democrats have to
sit down with us and we have to work
something out very easily on Asylum and
on loopholes
well it could happen but I want to bring
it further down the line look in the
meantime he's kept his word
there's no nuclear testing there's no
large you know long-range missiles going
up the only thing he set up were very
short-term short-range and that was just
a test of short-range it's a whole
different deal but he's kept his word to
me that's very important and again the
letter he sent was a beautiful letter
was a very warm letter that's a very
nice thing and I don't say that out of
naivete I say that was a very nice look
[Music]
this will go into and this will go into
effect and it's my option it's not
mexico's but it will go into effect when
Mexico tells me it's okay to release it
if they bring the numbers way down we
won't have to use it if they bring the
numbers way down we won't have to but
this is my option it goes into effect
when I wanted to but I have a lot of
respect for the President of Mexico I
have a lot of respect for the people we
dealt with so I don't want to do that
and they have to go back to Congress to
get that approved but it goes down
listen it it goes down it it goes into
effect at my option but I wouldn't do
that I want to deal with them
[Music]
well I have defense secretary I have
it's done I put it out yeah it's done
from the standpoint of the nomination
wait wait wait
Pat Shanahan was nominated to it yeah no
I put it out I put it out officially no
now he has to go through the process
he's now going through that we'll make a
determination I think Kevin is doing a
very good job right now but we'll make a
determination and not too distant we
have active will make a determination
but I think Kevin is doing a very good
job I hope that everything works out
with Iran Iran is a country that now
because of all of the sanctions and
other things is a much different country
than when I came here when I came here
they were all over the place causing
terror causing problems they're not
doing that right now and I think they
respect the United States right now much
more than they ever have so Iran's got a
lot of problems and I'd like to help
them with those problems we'll see what
happens
but they have tremendous inflation their
money is worthless
you can't buy a loaf of bread it's a lot
of problems in a rent that's a lot
different than it was two and a half
years ago and big things were sanctions
but I think the biggest thing was when I
turned the most important was when I
terminated the Iran nuclear deal which
was an incompetent deal thank you all
I'll see you in Iowa
[Music]